where is this freezer it's around
here right down here Gord
let so this is the Frozen bit here
what's
that Frozen avocado are we not in
Florida and you can't make fresh
avocado dude this is [__] where's the
freeer main walking
wow wow wow when was the last time you
were in here I come in here once a week
at least and I kind of you know just
kind of look around or whatever what is
this wow oh
man look at that the water's gone slimy
yeah and you come in here once a week
yeah what is
that oh
boy [__] hell what is that that P
colada pina colada why it's like that I
have no idea it's fested it's it's it's
off it's
bubbling oh man that's terrible [__]
trash please
trash James trash please now peina
colada right down the drain by the
bucket load in the walk-in
fridge I mean who in the hell operates
like this Gordon this is Chef Ben's job
he's the executive chef he's the
executive chef and you made him that
executive chef right sure I did how'd
you feel
now what's that tuna burger that's from
the burger yes it is oh my god seriously
bacon it's gone it's it's it's off fresh
produce on top of old produce moldy and
this one ribey ribey defrosting what is
this those are the smoke grilled chicken
wings before they go onto the char grill
oh my God and what is in this
one you are kidding me so underneath in
that bucket is what cooked product
cooked chicken and on top of it is what
it's raw raw chicken on top of cooked
chicken I had them for
lunch I am at a [__] loss do you know
the best way out of this is just to shut
the place
down it's not an option for
me what's that in there Ben those are
marinated chicken wings yeah to be
smoked underneath next
box those are smoked rule number [__]
one Ben I know Chef I didn't do it you
know I turn my back for a minute and
this is the kind of [__] that happens I
walked in and it was
bedam MH mhm he's telling me this is
your fault you've got no idea I am at a
absolute [__]
loss I can't work like this this is huge
you now are running a restaurant cross
contaminated you okay yeah no I'm fine
I'm okay when were the chickens roasted
2 days ago that's the last of them why
do we roast them two days in advance
they're delivered twice a week they're
cooked off the delivery day what kind of
impression do you think you're sending
out to your C when that chicken's
roasted 2 days before they come I I I
I when did you think this chicken was
roasted oh my goodness I hope it was
today it was roasted 2 and a half days
ago I am not happy to hear that at all
that was going to be dry as a dog bone
but anyway uh try to enjoy okay thanks I
don't feel well anymore thank you I will
try they've been coming for 12 years you
need to just seriously just focus on
getting this night done and they sit
there all schmuck I want to kick them
out right now do you want us to take the
food back I mean this is like so
disappointing that you guys feel this
way I thought we were friends and I I
thought you would have maybe told us if
you felt the food sucked that much you
know it's really gosh I feel I feel like
I want to pass out right now [__]
know um so the lady you just talking to
over there had no idea her chicken was
roasted 2 and a half days ago it was
roasted two and a half days ago yeah I
didn't know that okay f i me it's not my
business with him just I'm just God you
two are so defensive there's a thousand
different ways to make SP I've got
nothing to do with that I'm talking
about the chicken I'd love to find out
the proper chicken I'm talking to about
the chicken well Mak
excuse Focus nothing resonates with you
does it nothing it certainly does AB it
all
does
what in the hell I just wanted to keep
it together tonight that's
all crazy are you like manic or
something I'm manic yes I am right
now how's it going guys uh something
between shitty and awful what does it
mean when you feels like an elephant
sitting on your chest oh you don't have
a heart you can't have a heart attack
are you hungry Gordon what is
this that is bacon should be on a
different shelf and this here that
shouldn't be thrown there
either what's that beer batter for the
beer batter shrimp should be thrown
out and this one let me just St that on
top put it right on top what is all
this that
was bacon I no no that's okay no why is
it in your fridge like this I dropped it
one shelf below instead of putting where
it belonged I put it on the corner
normally these things are pretty orderly
this is a complete cluster
book What's thatn
Beef let's let's get outside let's go
outside what is going on the whole
operation is screwed the kitchen
shocking the line disaster cross
contaminated raw meat cooked meat [__]
everywhere and then the biggest asset
where all the money is is downstairs in
the wi seller who's maintaining
standards here he is I cannot believe
what you just done in
there I really enjoy it you can't enjoy
that I swear to God I do I I must be
like cucko in the head or something or
you need help maybe he does you need to
wake up pulling back that RI eyes like
pulling back that duv on my mattress
Blood Stained
and wow that's strong in alcohol 's a
good wine for this right AR Gina claims
her hands are tied in the kitchen so at
this point I don't know who to blame
that rice is mush who cooked that it's
like oatmeal what the [__] Idaho rainbow
trout with the her Roto Jesus what's all
the uh squidy bits around the outside
those are all the sauces all the sauces
yeah yeah seriously
yeah ah is that risotto or some of the
plas that your dad left over from
building the new
Lodge it's still got the scales on it as
as well why would you leave the skin
that's soggy like some used
condom that has to be the worst trout
I've ever seen in my entire
career wow does Mom and Dad see this
food do they come and have dinner they
hate everything they hate the the dish
or everything they don't like the way
that she does anything and why is she
here when you're in the heat of the
Season we kind of just take what we can
get you can't keep on changing your Chef
every year I I agree we do it every year
[__] it
now if this place wasn't run by your
parents would you work here hell no not
not for a second I don't want to run a
restaurant how Keen are you to get out I
I'm desperate and if you got a job
tomorrow would you be off yeah I feel
like I've kind of done my part the part
that I told him that I would do you're
obviously concerned and you're doing it
more out of affection I suppose that you
really want to be here sounds like your
mind's made up
[Music]
mhm
Wow Let's get them out
please would you both come out please
both of us would you come out both of
you what of I don't want
to sherff Ramsey nice to meet you
likewise good to see you too wow uh so
I'm lost for words what feedback did you
get throughout my lunch I I didn't say
anything say word nothing at all not yet
course by course you didn't even talk to
them why not I figured that was what you
were going to do when we were done I was
hoping at least you're going to say
something to them so they can up the
gain no I actually expected you to say
something and I thought well should I
ask or I kept thinking okay must be okay
I haven't heard any
comments don't you want the truth oh
absolutely do you know the owners hate
your dishes no you don't know the owners
hate your food no I did not know that
you've got no idea that Dei can't stand
the curry no I never knew that I feel
like people have been lying to me J I
don't blame her let me I'm going to be
frank the ribi was overcooked it looked
like we'd opened at the bottom of the
dishwasher and that plug was blocked
with bits of floating
grease God you may find it funny but
you're not no it was funny the way you
just described no but art I mean no I'm
not trying to laugh about the real no
[__]
hell look where we're sat though if you
phone me on my telephone in the car and
ask me what do you think I'm going to be
having I would never have mentioned
those dishes you did nothing to blow me
away I'm trying to use the ingredients
that Dave asked me to use a lot of it is
cost so I was tied to that art you're
the Sue Chef is there any Synergy in
what you're doing
no you're just doing it to survive no
one's thinking longterm
it's stifling the
business I'm amazed you're still open
Zach I don't know if you've got one foot
in one foot out you shouldn't be here
[__] hell Frozen Frozen
Frozen wow not even wrapped where are
the burgers I mean it just doesn't look
anything like a burger and when it's
processed like that and stamped and
pressed you can just tell right frozen
food wow Bret come with me yeah how's
the fet cheating it's okay
not the best damn I'm sorry um Burgers a
burger cooked here locally would you
expect that to be frozen or fresh fres
the burger is not frozen it's the
patties and everything come in frozen
and they're thought out is that like
most people you thought it out so it's
not frozen then it comes in
Frozen yeah you throw it out and that to
the your customers is not a frozen
Burger
well stay there let me just show you
[Music]
something I'm waiting for him to come
back he's going to ream me on something
oh boy here we go
mhm so there's your bugers it's a frozen
thank you now your husband said it
wasn't no what do you mean no it's it's
it's frozen of course I never said that
it wasn't it we thought it out here it
comes in Frozen yeah it's still a frozen
Burger there's no such thing as a fresh
burger at least at least here in Eastern
Washington we cannot get fresh there's
no fruit you find me the Burger come
with me yeah good evening welcome please
come in out the cold are you joining yes
quick question do you love a burger yeah
I Burger Madam yes would you expect them
to be made fresh here or frozen fresh
fresh are you going to tell them what
should I tell them freshh all the way no
should we tell them the truth I mean
that's what we want to do well we we
our our Burgers come in Frozen and we
thaw them out but throwing them out
doesn't make them fresh thank you
appreciate it thank you thank you thanks
for coming you guys welcome ladies hey
folks how are you quick question coming
out for dinner would you expect a frozen
Burger to be served here tonight or a
fresh one fresh fresh you going to tell
them or should I tell them I'll let you
tell them oh come on you own the place
well we all of our beef that we get in
Burgers it comes in Frozen our burgers
and we and we thaw them out which in his
mind convinces him it's fresh oh does
that make it sound any better no thank
you we're still glad to have you thank
you you you bet oh my God after Brent
tried to convince me that there were no
fresh burgers in town H I almost cry
it's okay you did good I'm proud of you
I walked directly across the street and
ordered one so that's the lamburger
Bur
nice to see you coming to a restaurant
like this would you expect your Burgers
to be fresh or frozen fresh Burgers come
in Frozen and with th
out that's the story thank you so that
is a
lamburger fresh I'm getting sick to
death of this denial denial denial
you've been making up [__] all
[__] day yes yes you have all your
staff have the same thing to say passive
aggressive condescending ing
inappropriate and
stubborn no absolutely not the staff the
way you treat them what there you go
again no no no you're just scared about
employing a team that's going to tell
you the truth that is [__] that is
not cuz you don't like them confronting
you with the truth you fire them no I
haven't fired anybody I heard that you
fired your son oh
[__] you don't even know the [__]
story he was having some issues going
and I told I was aware of the alcohol I
was aware of that right I was trying to
save his life yeah my brother's a drug
addict we put him in rehab seven times
unsuccessfully I don't give up on him
but what I'm more concerned about is
that nothing's affecting you it's like
we're doing great in generally the place
runs quite
well oh my God we're shutting it
down you just send everybody home stop
stop that is POS must be the worst thing
I've seen so far how'd you reheat that
in the microwave in the
microwave doesn't even hit an oven but
we used to cook them fresh right so what
what changed I wasn't here yeah so what
happened stop I'm not serving in it stop
what happened ask Karen I ain't the one
that bought the chickens I have rather
have a rotis thing back here I can have
fresh chicken we need new equipment this
is what is Ed in this is what we're Ser
you can't buy this from a grocery store
you can't sprinkle it with pasty and
expect to call yourselves a restaurant I
know what you I know what you're saying
and you just like a butterfly fly around
just painting all little bits of [__]
over holes this is insane I'm done I'm
I'm upset I'm I'm feeling sick and I've
never seen such a disgusting mess in all
my [__] life this embarrassment to
you you you and me and I'm not going to
stand there and watch you serve [__]
like that and take customers money what
is
this I eat them often the rotisseries
you eat them often M what does that say
I guess it's just that I
don't what does that mean to you you eat
this crap
often come
on you're running a
hotel the burgers were cooked
yesterday well when I ate them and I
always tell them they tasted good to me
God where's the burgers that you cooked
down here sir get them I my
understanding is he patting them out and
then put them in the oven how long for
for about 15 20 minutes 15 20 minutes in
an oven how many of your customers
expect Burgers to be cooked like that
baked in the oven for 20 minutes so
there's no color on there cooled down
stuck in a zip Locker bag out boiled in
water should we go and do another survey
what's 80% Chuck it's just h you are
seriously in denial Miss Sarah would you
like a bite no thank you why not it's
not cooked right well should I boil it
up for you and get it warm what color is
that it's
white that's what frustrates me we're
all pretending that this is
good I thought that's what the cooks I
mean come on not I mean I'm not trying
to blame it on the cooks but you can't
blame it on me because ain't nobody
hearing me I'm amazed you're not shut
down frieza's lined up next to a
dumpster what lives outside in those
passageways next to dumpsters bat rats
and Alat yeah bats rats and
mice you are in
denial you have a big problem you've got
no idea that this place is
crumbling and you're just going through
the
motions Mr Ramsey my guest want to leave
your guest want to leave yes that's the
best thing I've heard all day can I
[__] join
them you are we serving food at all I
let them leave and we're in danger of
even being shut down by the health
authorities and there is no [__] way
I'm going to stand there and watch this
[__] being reheated and served so sorry
we're not moving
forward